I remember when I left off last you guys
are something that we're getting to the
the hard parts of the game which which
is fun cuz I thought we'd already we're
already in the hard part so the hard
part is pretty much the whole game so
yeah this is gonna be interesting
carry on in secret laboratory no we are
not playing Dexter's Laboratory okay
yeah so we just go into the laboratory I
remember I went to check out like the
NAP room right and I couldn't get there
so I was like well I've discussed all
playing bed so what was the aim of game
what am i doing when you haven't played
a game for a few weeks and you forget oh
yeah so I was going to the NAP room
there's a lot of here though in the
cafeteria so maybe we'll go in there
yeah why not - the stores lot so it's
not like oh unless we can jump through
oh no II I think we did this cuz white
weight well what do I know
wait I don't think we did do that
[Applause]
a mother game get to the NAP room now
proves our frick'n well I say that I've
never actually had it not room of my own
I've always wanted to work in an
establishment that has an opera in them
basically Google in the US hello okay so
this is the locked room okay so there
must be either the glass and here either
the glass in here is shuttered which I'm
guessing that's probably the case can I
get through here if I jump through here
into the glass
what the [ __ ] oh yeah I'm punched in the
face right so where's this ladder oh
that is very nice
[Applause]
also I've been reading up I've been
always shooting their heads and
sometimes the heads don't actually the
head shots don't stun them and they just
don't react to head shots so what I
should be doing is actually aiming for
their legs and then they'll stumble and
I can technically go around them
apparently
[Applause]
see that's what I felt like it into out
with together hmmm well sir can't get me
now can you know yeah you walk away just
don't climb that ladder please are us
units on the Rawdon honor
what's the key has brains okay no that's
good
[Applause]
it would make sense that our herbs in
here come on seriously
maybe in these
okay well I was right at least about the
way that we're going let's go to the NAP
room wait I'm confused
where's the other side of that hand oh
okay it's underneath the metal you know
I don't really want to I probably don't
need that wristband that right I can put
that away
well we'll do that in a second math math
[Applause]
what do you mean so I'm still nevis now
and um
say hi to this guy I guess give him a
high five or something oh cool
[Applause]
it's not gonna mean he's a handsome girl
Mitch
[Applause]
just cut it off we can use his
fingerprints so I guess we can use this
get back out ah good but it's probably
not gonna be as safe as I imagined it to
be
what
and let's all match up with General
Staff level but this is General Staff so
it should be allowed this is General
Staff let me through I've got a General
Staff card what the hell how do I use it
come insert it into the wristband oh I
just have to read it that makes sense
thank you right
by the way I know he's hurt but he can
take a at least one more here and then
I'll heal him I okay here we go
oh so this is probably why I should have
read before so I would have understood
that this is what the wristband was for
not just for getting me in because I
thought it's just to get me in an issue
then I could have just thrown away yeah
electronic chips okay so that's what I
just picked up and that's why I just put
in them make sense read it the wrong way
around but
sit down wake up
ooh cool target moving to the west area
must be going to retrieve the g-virus
and antiviral agent
this is ghosts understood rendezvous
point w3 Roger this is alpha arrived at
destination understood standby target
this is alpha I've got eyes on the
target he's going to open the safe Roger
awaiting signal wait who's a target got
eyes on the g-virus we're going in
dr. Bracken you'll come along with us
quietly
[Applause]
nope nope nope
senior staff clearance required for each
box
Austin you need to craft the diamond
sword before you fight the ender dragon
the ended
dragon dragon okay this is cool oh I
know Liana I'm being so mean I just
don't want to waste your stuff right now
right he said but I'm in pain ah thank
you that's good okay oh look at that
ah so there's the key card that we need
what happened here
[Applause]
see yourself famous required for
computer access
hmm oh god what
okay this it's pretty overgrown you can
do this dead people
[Applause]
yes yes it's yes yes yes let's make some
shotgun oh my why is the music egg weird
I don't like huh
nope shotgun that one okay should I do
like okay can I shoot you I don't know
if I can I can please shoot you in the
frickin I don't know what that was the
parts that are supposed to hurt the most
right Oh dark side you know I was I was
reading up about this game
and mr. X is genuinely walking around
the environment the whole time you play
the game and that means that it actually
can result in a bug where you get event
mr. axe and roaming mister eggs at the
same time you have to mr. x's hopefully
that never happens in this playthrough
might as well try though right
what is this thank you
why did I do that use a flame player on
the plant some bees thank you for your
advice dispersing various solutions into
the greenhouse okay so do I use this
with no I just have it here okay so I
guess I can move that around the
environment and disperse it within the
environment okay there's nothing else
here really no no a8 No
okay okay I guess
oh this is cool I don't know why to go
I'm a bit oh okay not that way
let's just go straight on seems the most
obvious way to go Oh Oh guys guys guys
do we write it down joy everybody on my
hand
okay well everyone okay hi guys
let's go ah hi
okay cute back again let's let's put
this in
I feel like I'm a kid again this why you
do another kid I always used to have a
little notebook with me is that the same
one as this one yep nice okay
let's have a little Scout around here
testing lab place an empty cartridge
into the solution dispenser that add the
required amount of um be cool
immediately plant 43 exhibits around us
starting what plant 43 exhibits
astounding growth if something
unfortunate were to occur it may be hard
to control in the event of an unforeseen
incident - right to the herbicide using
the instructions above okay plant an
empty cartridge into Spencer add the
required amount okay I don't have that
you gotta cool it I don't know where to
find all that stuff ah see it's been
ripped off oh I can't find it on my hand
but I don't think I'd be any point but I
will anyway
okay
I guess I'll just look for a the closest
save room and I can come back that to
get the stuff scales still if I missed
okay oh [ __ ] Suraj oh yeah they either
wait wait wait this freakin oh hi are
you dead okay
is this why I opened I think so
what's this maps yes nice
hmm no blood
[Applause]
[ __ ] it's not what I think it is I
thought I had mr. X walking around but
no I think there's a random thud it's
okay I think I don't know I'm not too
short
um oops it's not kick things please stop
oh yeah I trophy but again I can't keep
it
I need to find a safe room it's got to
be something you always alone
Oh does the groom have that - it's
nothing here that I can use
I can't believe none of these of getting
up and attacking me I feel very blessed
right now right it's fine to save room
there's got to be one around here
somewhere
yes Jesus Christ just let me get your
freaking savouring I'm just on edge
right now save her save her there you go
take ticket take it I'm looking for a
safe room Oh God get in there yells dark
face ah hello cool don't worry we're
gonna go back in actually look around
it's night craft of bed you have to go
to sleep to get rid of the vomit is
reloading casually Hey
oh [ __ ] Betsy no one
Oh Tommy you got me I think this is what
we need I think this is what we need
hmm yes yeah blending on things hey
honey
oh my god [ __ ]
Thanks got you in the legs got you in
the legs you guys down
let's go back in that's fun
[Applause]
Oh where'd you come from I run right
into him
freaking everywhere dude
why did I front in that green era it was
around here somewhere
ah better not run past it yeah I know
don't worry once we find your a green
herb we're gonna be using it straight
away balls balls balls the liquor I
forgot about you [ __ ] on a stick
obviously reto I was talking about the
headshots they don't work they sometimes
work but most the time leg shorts work
better oh my god okay I think I'm dead
now yes so with headshots they only work
sometimes sometimes you can get
headshots and they literally don't work
I don't know if if you guys have played
this but it is really difficult
and most of the time the zombies don't
die anyway if they get back up so but
that's the aim of the game you're not
supposed to be able to feel overpowered
if you did wouldn't be a very good
present evil game okay my try going the
other way
oh wait yeah just go back and get that
blue herb yeah so like actually when
it's it's really interesting if you see
reviews on this game because I'm wasn't
it IGN or something I got called out for
it
there are basically complaining that it
was too hard because the zombies would
always get back up and sometimes
headshots didn't do anything but that's
actually the point of it's the point of
it let's not forget guys that there is a
liquor in here but this also resolving
so that kind of makes it worse there's a
liquor but there's a freakin zombie
oh no no nope nope oh can I knew this um
be this way can you just follow me in
here so I can queue in here and then go
and sneak past the liquor cuz I'll be
really nice I can't I'm - I'm freaking
out now [ __ ] me in the ass just go why
am i saying these things on stream come
on freaking the [ __ ] out I just go just
go just go just go just go just go just
go just pick up this I didn't pick up
the frickin hands live although
everywhere how am I supposed to defeat
liquids and zombies I can't freaking do
this oh my god
it's there it's right there
but it's okay we're gonna be slightly
scared we did it how would the retail
stay that don't know but we did it okay
so what did we just pick up so we got a
chance up and shared one that's good
this gun is like oh okay uh yeah what I
don't need to write this on my hand
that's great
something right on the bottom okay let's
go back to that main room then and put
that in and then also I guess we can go
back to the first room because we've got
this box and I reckon that's what we use
in the other place this is what we came
down with me yeah oh no I just
remembered where this leads though I
don't like this one either oh my god
they're getting back up there's a blue
hair up though that's nice
no no they don't like to fire
that's what my subscribers tell me so
that's what I do
okay lovely gorgeous fabulous right
let's put these codes down on what
thank you for your subscription um no no
align this two and a bit line there okay
let's go back to drugs do not edit that
out of context okay
hi guys hope you're doing well today I'm
in the lovely plant room okay now we can
use this
manual no engage adjust another solution
to match cartridge capacity to large
cartridge capacity
is that right
cuz that looks pretty large to me or
always that wrong oh I think I've got to
get it to the line well that would make
sense wouldn't it say would that work
yes okay cool and now we can go back to
the other room I'm guessing and disperse
that into the environment that surrounds
us
I'm so glad mr. X isn't here yeah she
says I know he's coming
[Applause]
okay it's just
what of course I have to cool it how do
I call it where would I go to cool it is
it back in the drug testing I don't
think there's anywhere to cool what do
you reckon guys
so many would a Oh low temp testing lab
that sounds about right
don't you think hi fans oh god they're
not there now I'm uneasy
oh I look at you oh this work no okay
just can't go up there
well I tried publishing stick around I
have a feeling they're gonna get back up
Vergil the shrimp wants a hug on twitch
guys go to twitch and give Virgil a hug
this the room with the lookers yeah Shh
we actually have to be quiet this time
we're not gonna run through here like a
lunatic like last time okay
[ __ ] a duck in the ass it's right there
as well I really don't want to I'm just
gonna have to try and take these zombies
out that's okay I'm just going to try
and take them out seats so the way
that's it's pretty interesting to
explain exact the way that zombies work
is like if you use a shotgun in the head
that's the best way because then you can
look blow their heads up but most of the
time you shoot them in the head
sometimes they don't react sometimes
they do react sometimes they fall down
but then they usually get back up and
then you go shoot them a few times to
actually blow their head of completely
him but once the head is like this this
they're not gonna get back up again so
that's good done now I have my knife so
let's do this look at that it was fine
spiny spine there was a rumor that if
you hit them right in the bum hole that
they die instantly but that's a lie so
I'm not gonna do that but I need to get
over there what was that one just do you
guys him Oh God
hi do you guys remember what it was
called
I'm just gonna do it more I did we know
it wasn't math cuz I remember math I
guess we need to be right up close to it
don't mean all this sucks I don't want
to be up close to it
Jesus thank you for following Jesus
ah there's notifications get me every
day
kill them fries but I want to kill the
look is like as a frickin heart I can't
kill the Lucas is it grenade I don't
have a grenade
[Applause]
okay we just got two more to kill in
here we can do that we can just kill the
zombies then we can just slide past
Opel's oh come on you being freaking
serious Oh
[ __ ] balls okay there we go I'm
actually not bad at dodging Silica's
yeah now I can walk away but there's
that just that one zombie that's um it's
just very precariously placed I wish I
could just launch my knife at in you
know just chuck him in a bucket his head
hey guys oh that song though
[Applause]
thank you for subscribing
Jesus Christ I can't or this oh hello
that was easy okay right
oh my god the lights
go-go-go-go
what did I just do literally why did I
do that what was what was the purpose of
doing that do they unlock a room
[Applause]
because I still can't get here oh my god
I can't good thank goodness okay it's
cool oh very very very cool that's large
I think the other ones large as well you
have to buy yes nice we have another
knife
you ask you must stay dead
Oh God
okay
Oh are they are so annoying so when I
get to the other door I need to get to
this one it should be unlocked now
your dinner - dinner - to - to du du-de
du-de du-de - dude why are you not going
fire oh I just put myself on fire I'm
only singing that so that I'm not scared
wrong
now let's see this shipyard I think we
can now collect our knife as well
Oh No okay that was the end of the knife
anyway okay so now that we killed those
two let's save the game again tothis a
Naruto do you personally like or dislike
romance it's a weird question to ask I
like romance as long as it's genuine I
guess
but don't hit the things on the floor Oh
God
look who's coming just just go just go
just go just go
Oh God just go just go just go just go
what the hell just go just go just go is
fine you're fine okay good you just go
not freak out and the knickers aren't so
bad
I just don't run and don't touch them
and don't let them touch you what's in
here
oh yes of course the coolant the coolant
hmm right it's all right Leon you can
hock it for a little bit longer we just
need to find you a new horrible
something like I'm not dr. me
mmm-hmm is there another look around you
okay
thanks for the funnel wins
Wayne Lee's box what's he up to
can you believe that bastard Cartwright
cool your jets [ __ ]
well I guess he is the boss for now
anyway have you seen my keylex anyone I
put the secret on the bottom let me know
if you find it so you couldn't make our
little meeting
fine don't worry about the greenhouse
inspection instead I'll give you
something real simple to do put together
the budget estimate for the year after
next and get it done right are you alive
we're under attack people are dead these
areas cut off we can't operate the verge
with the response we have here where is
that faster Cartwright Harding plant 43
is going wild the greenhouses hell we
need to send someone in there before
it's too late
Wayne how do we stop this thing you have
to help us please reply German for Susie
the cheerleader what a great gal we're
both into her why are the pre-fight a
something to my Susie okay uncle's she
wasn't into nerds
of course she's management's this will
have to empty you back giving you back
those comics and games I've art but you
might have to wait a while why are we
suddenly talking about Susie I love that
does little things like that that just
bring the world to life okay
dönitz Susie why don't you like nerds
you could like read comics and play the
games together me so nice okay
Leon stop your bloody whining this is
what we've been looking for this entire
time we need to cool down this is what
we need no not this one although you
probably do need that one actually you
are a Jacob shotgun is your friend with
a zombies
a dark phone you never used the knife I
find the knife reels useful but you're
right I haven't really used the board of
windows much although I did board up the
windows in the police station near one
of the safe rooms and that was a really
good call
because you always walk past there and
there's always somebody's trying to get
through there cool cool cooling complete
it's cool okay
I'm gonna start with my roadie bad puns
so even a pants not witty at all it's
okay Leon don't worry we're going back
out now let's go back out and then I
will allow you to go to the save point
cuz I'm a great gal I think there's
always this way though gobi castle so
anything down around here I always think
there's gonna be stuff underneath the
stairs okay what's that weird ass noise
thank you for subscribing but I'm too
freaked out now lordy Lordy they're
everywhere
good wait hold up oh god I missed oh my
god right
at least you're down for now for now oh
Jesus Christ oh no I missed again I got
to stop wasting ammo not the best
decision before was this can I use this
what is this somebody's no everybody
turned verified they keep coming back
again and again burn them all burn oh
okay thank you but my subscribers
already told me this uh yeah I don't eat
Caesar it's like I don't need the game
and it's useful hints when I'm live
streaming and I can just cheat let me
get tips from you guys don't worry I
haven't forgot that we also had the
other room to go back to but we're gonna
go put this frozen solution in where it
needs to go
[Applause]
The Grudge didn't know you were there
huh skated turn around run away
stealthily kill one and then just kept
cool by the other yep
that sounds about right okay
oh these routes gonna count the way now
oh so I can get to him how do I get that
okay let's do this I've been a bad boy
okay let's find this man
where's he gone though how do I get over
there though oh my god why you read that
it's probably not a very good sign
oh yes wonderful got the chip I gots the
chips oh just go
don't even look back I know who it is I
know I'm not happy about it so let's
just freakin it go I'm glad you can save
hard
I mean pause okay let's go oh no okay no
Jesus I leave me alone leave me oh no
please sir please please please please
leave me alone - please no Joey means to
me give my head like that this is not
very nice mr. just coming please leave
me alone please leave me alone please
email and please leave me alone teasing
me oh my God my God my God my God my God
I died
it's go and give it to you go and give
it to you oh my god okay
do I even care though
if you will get aniline I might be able
to strategically hit you all at the same
time make you die there you go yes
that's good line up from me model come
on guy dude get over this way oh oh uh
oh no papa
I was trying to be strategic nothing god
I pushed him off I'm a lucky boy right
I'll be ready why not ready uh hi I'm
not ready Oh No
let's go ex-con give it to you go and
give it to you it's gone give it to you
I'm not running through the frickin
spices oh that's one thing I'm not gonna
bloated you and I should have killed
this guy she's going back hip fries I
should have killed this one why haven't
I killed you yet ex-con give it to you
it's gonna give it to you ex-con give it
to you aah ex can't follow me in here
right now this is the safe room
[Music]
think we're okay I think we're safe
oh no be cool though if you saw him
walking around out here I mean that's
kind of cool I can see one of the plant
dudes that's really cool actually what
we just jumped down here now where is he
I think he is out there somewhere oh
this is too creepy for me I like it a
lot
okay when did nest become a nest for
spies last three months and another for
this month and those are just the ones
we caught step up security cowboy or do
you want to end up like your predecessor
also I'll be restricting access to the
West area from today ignore all quests
from headquarters for information on gee
those suits contribute nothing to this
project anyway herbicide dispersal by
unauthorized employee detected in the
east area I guess I wish this super job
thank freakin scared me joystick James I
wasn't done here I wanted to read the PC
because you could only read it once you
had though there are yous guys hello hey
sexy do you like tall dark and handsome
guys cuz there's one right now he's just
misunderstood right let's go stop
talking crap about mr. X is there
anything that I've missed that I want to
go back for sort of me not should we go
all the way back to the NAP room because
we've got this little box thing now yeah
I'm gonna go back there done it's ready
for you muff what am I saying
thanks for subscribe be aware that the
here
no no no no no no we fight we fight we
fight we fight we fight hmm that's an
interesting way to die
yes oh I'm glad I did that I'm very glad
we did that
did God blood everyone what the hell's
happening they're dead they're all dead
it was us men in black USS headquarters
Special Forces but why isn't that job to
protect us
white brains and a sea of red this can't
be happening
did God why didn't everybody say oh
thanks for subscribing didn't everybody
say I was a genius a genius like me
can't die in a place like this I always
cut the cells they're screwing me both
maybe
thanks for subscribing maybe uh screw
them
I'll win the Nobel I'm a hero a genius a
god
I will not die I will he died you
definitely died and now you you're dead
in a very precarious position with your
console on the floor so sorry God okay
let's carry on where the hell's X I ran
away from him apparently I won't see him
until the end of the games this is this
is good I'm happy about this why aren't
you happy about this
oh yeah because you want to see me
scream yeah let's go Leon it's me and
you all the way
okay so apparently these guys don't ever
get up so that's good oh yes I love
watching videotapes what does this one
say operation nest wrecker cool that's
gonna be useful
although you guys could have just told
me that I won't see mr. X just to put me
out and the like at ease at unease at
ease so that I don't get freaked out but
I'm gonna say that you wouldn't do that
to me OSs
thank you
oh okay maybe time oh we didn't eat that
anymore okay hey Tom
[Applause]
[Applause]
dr. Birkin they've come along with us
quietly think I know you're coming this
is my life's work
I'm not handing over anything we have
our orders
dr. Birkin I'll ask you one more time
[Applause]
mmm
[Applause]
what were you thinking
our orders running free him in a line
we're in we had a nap
target with we had to take him on
[Applause]
that's correct sir
Roger that
[Applause]
let's move
so those 4G sales
yeah and I'm sure we're gonna probably
bump into him at some point suspending
research on G the umbrella corporation
is decided to cease all research on G
which was ongoing at the nest
underground laboratory all funding for
this project has been cut and laboratory
director William broken has been removed
from his post
thank you for your mail doctor back in
top brass has expressed an interest in
this evolving bioweapon you mentioned me
do not worry about costs our company is
the most well funded in the whole us I
heard the good news G is almost ready
strange you never thought to report so
the research lab here at and brother HQ
but I suppose I can either slide anyway
send over the data would you under why
you don't good work on G but we can take
care of the rest
you are under suspicion of breaching
your contract for the young for a
corporation it has become clear that
you've claimed ownership of the G
product put out and have been in
unauthorized contact with the US
military places born to the
investigation committee sermons in 24
hours okay so that's why it all got cut
blue herd though
cool
ah yes let's make some more shotgun
actually let's wait till all let's go in
here I think I've got some large gun
powder in my shiest
why am i having a shower
okay I am not clean I am not infected
even though I've been bitten so many
times oh cool oh cool okay you get into
the cool sci-fi lab stuff
I'm ready called
what is that what is that
anything down here
[Applause]
Oh God all right back table
no no yeah
oops Oh
after the G embryo was implants in the
subject we made a 50 centimeter incision
for the chest to the abdomen and began
our observations with the help of the
medical team the subjects consciousness
level was kept between 15 bar
however the subjects consciousness level
deteriorated and further observation was
deemed necessary the subject was then
disposed of G virus was administered to
subject fiber one remember when we
tasted in DG form was introduced to a
group of 30 test subjects after 2 hours
36 minutes it was observed that one but
all but one sorry of the test subjects
have been implanted with an embryo all
subjects were disposed of one subject
broke down during experimentation and
took their own life of course
we administered the g-virus to subtract
6 to 8 who had shown slight resistance
the t-virus the virus was then
introduced as subject 6 3 9 with whom in
68 had a close relationship 6 to 8 sewed
some signs of resistance but had been
implanted with an embryo after 24
minutes Tavares resisted does resistance
does nothing to stop the mental
deterioration okay oh please don't
balls please own self describe I haven't
haven't finished looting [ __ ] I should
have saved the game first - okay
whatever
redhead
[Applause]
I have so much
okay
oh it's the help me guy oh hey
going on
all this thing going on
why
[Applause]
so
groans
your umbrella too
you tell me you weren't involved in this
but we never meant for this to happen
[Applause]
tell me everything right from the start
[Applause]
[Music]
what have you done
[Applause]
so you made this monster
but never intended to spin it any way
you want no no no no no stop talking
coming
I have no great hello me guy
[Music]
okay duck in the ass whatever go
can I crawl an event oh my god I can't
even get to your bloody eye oh I'm gonna
die I'm gonna die I just want to get
past you please okay great
fabulous just go
oh my god I thought he would be like
down for a no but not good my half to a
third frickin bomb at him what's this
what what did I just pick up
oh he's gonna shuck something at me I'm
dead I'm definitely dead oh my god okay
so he Chuck's things at me there's
things that I can pick up no I don't
want to switch the emesis okay
apparently this health spray in the
fighting area that's good so I won't
search for that as soon as I get down
there
carry on oh sure right I don't know how
I just did that I think it knew that I
was [ __ ] and it was like oh yeah already
done this before how you suck right Oh
balls
where is the pickable items cuz I need
them cuz I need then keep going keep
going keep going keep going just one
just one just one just one just one
Oh God Oh God
okay but I need some help okay oh my god
you're on fire
get up
I can't find the freaking health oh good
I'm on fire
can't see I'm shooting
oh Jesus Christ hard
I'm see me again [ __ ] pissed off of
this right come on keep going yeah I'm
gonna swear a lot just it's okay
sorry mom uh no no can I roll no I can't
but it's okay oh Jesus
all right we've got them in the end we
got them in the end okay okay
is the exotic no no no no Jews have [ __ ]
to you piss off dick sucker ah
Oh
Oh Kelly [ __ ] it why not
oh these guns oh [ __ ] you you little eye
babies you know I babies get you an eye
babies
are you being serious I think serious I
don't have any more I'm scared I can't
even turn to shoot oh god I can't do
this this is so hard ah I'm gonna don't
rage grain soon oh sorry what I have to
do twice okay I just get round the back
of here and wait till you hit me and
then try and go around the back of you
or wait until you start to rip a thing
off the wall and then I can get your eye
oh my girl that works so wild okay okay
okay I'm understanding how to play video
games you guys part of me there is give
me your eye
damnit i missed out I miss my chance I
blew it
I had one chance and I miss my chance to
blow this opportunity it came once
enough lifetime oh my god my control is
this way right now I can get your arm
out of the way sir I need to get to your
eyeballs sir
eyeballs please one on your leg oh no it
behind me to go right go go go
oh my god get away get the [ __ ] away oh
I'm in a wall I'm in a way that wasn't
fair
I was trapped for what seems like the
longest time oh my god don't please
Oh God okay where's his eyeball bo I'm
in so much stress right now
Oh God
Oh God what are you doing sir help
yes it was a cry like honestly that was
so annoying I'm so happy right now
oh okay
so uh anyway let's keep let's make sure
that we've definitely picked up
everything because we're just kind of
running around like a lunatic just then
okay we still have some shotgun ahmo's
which is nice via some normal
[Music]
worse
just tell me don't destroy that jisu
no7 it's it's gone the FBI
you trust that [ __ ]
is that supposed to be
she's gonna sell it
g-virus gonna go to the heist
[Music]
she votes
which it does oh oh well your dad
sheephead out and we are nearly dead
which I wish this just magically healed
us
[Applause]
[Applause]
Oh though she is
[Applause]
I was just thinking about you do we
trust her makes two of us
worried hey gonna ask you something
they're ready to sell
I ran its window before she died
why couldn't just hammer
want to trust you
I didn't
I really do
so that's all this was
I was just some pawn to you and I'm
doing mine so drop that damn gun I'm
taking you in
hand over the sample there's no one to
take her into you
and you should but I don't think you can
oh my gosh he's tense boom wait what ah
she wasn't dead
ah
it's not worth it
don't do this
take care of yourself
[Applause]
no she is ultimate badass doesn't even
care when she's doing
oh [ __ ] just let's just do this
Oh
Wow
two minutes until detonation
[Applause]
sit class ah hey
[Applause]
yeah the whole place is coming down
listen me we need to get out fast
there's a way out
[Applause]
we could make it
[Applause]
where are you now Claire are you still
there
hey I'm you're breaking up
forget about me just get out of here
damnit
heeey
okay exit right let's do this
Oh Shay what's this I am gonna die
one-hit-kill
like you Jimmy oh that's not good I love
this music
me too
Oh looking okay okay
no no this one
they only the fire no no Jesus using all
my things just get
what's this ah thank God I love you um
no I don't want to examine you only
combined and he is Oh yo
Oh goddamn
oh my god what are you doing oh hey
buddy
just jump through it no
[Music]
oh those types
gosh no no this is nice Oh damnit
should've waited oh well use at some
point is there safe here too or not what
the bloody hell is that
oh yes I mom this this is make sense
uh-oh
oh my gosh
he is actually invincible it's just
unstoppable okay guys it's the ultimate
puzzle and I am ready not okay oh god oh
I can't do this as like Stu freaking
soon after
Oh balls to you
I don't even know if I'm doing in him
and he done it oh my god
you okay I mean don't be okay oh god I
think I'm just wasting bullets oh okay
so apparently I just keep running and I
can't hurt him still so no I'm not gonna
switch to aim assist I'm just gonna keep
running
[Music]
[ __ ] what is this what it's what is
happening oh Jesus Christ
[Music]
[Music]
no no I mean Oh [ __ ] fools
okay oh my god it's horrendous
that's terrifying
hahahaha
again I have to get a different a
different save it's the countdown it's
making me feel really nervous even
though I know I have time right
where did I miss it I probably just
missed it again oh my god there you are
yes okay we might have a chance maybe
there we go yeah okay it's gonna be
another one here die die die die all of
you die dad
yeah
here he comes nope ex-con give it to ya
where the [ __ ] I can't even see him cuz
the smoke
okay here we go cutscene alright okay
okay
ah oh I'm getting hungry
I can smell food someone's cooking food
you know we can just forget you hungry
until you smell food and you're like oh
actually that smells good it's not good
okay we're in a much better position now
guys good hook oh lucky duck
in the book no I mean in their bundles
leave me from your firearm what the
[ __ ] hell was that
okay go go
doli on go go
[Music]
stunning 411 babe
how how I supposed to survive the
firearm
of the heart uneven notice that was on
show I thought it's just part of its
flash maybe I'll use my oh [ __ ] there's
no way office yeah I didn't think so
okay hi
oh he was not happy about that
[Music]
Oh God Thank You Wesley yes yes yes yes
yes I thought I thought I had another
grenade I was wrong but oh I wish the
box would just fall on your freaking
face Oh God come on come on come boy
come on boy oh we got this
oh well whatever we got here Oh a
present for me
hey she's alive
Oh God yep oops
yes Oh screw this where's where's my new
gun most fun one oh wow
I miss it okay that's add she doesn't
work that well get out of my way stupid
us zombies
this is so intense
we killed mr. X phone wait we left that
in the storage this is no acceptable
game
[Music]
did we finish his silence story then
Claire who is the little one you made it
just like I said
[Music]
I was full of emotions but I did it
we-we-we we won and broken I'm actually
broken we won with Leon anyway so who's
up for me playing as Claire next week
cuz uh yeah that was way too much fun
for one evening
but yeah thank you so much for watching
me thank you for all your hints and tips
and you just basically staying with me
while I made stupid mistakes and then I
learned from them and I lent and killed
and shot things and died a couple of
times and then defeated mr. eggs so
that's fun
I go see okay
I'll live with that see if I'm average
see if average 55 saves yeah I kind of
saved a lot I just say way too often but
I'm proud I'm just proud that I made it
through the game to be honest I tend to
get quite angry don't I get Freddie I
get pretty annoyed when I can kill
things well enough I'm like ah but it's
all in good fun yeah goodbye have enough
day or evening I will see you some other
time